as you know actors performers whatever
we look in the mirror
you know here's your hair all right
you're a persona you're you're someone
who's like larger than life and
especially during the the heyday where
you're winning the championships you're
you're like the biggest wrestler around
and do you did you
did you look in the mirror and kind of
like reenact what you're gonna
sort of like prepare what you're gonna
do like say i'm chris jericho and this
is like
some of the things just almost like
rehearse like writing lines of what
you're gonna say when
the microphones put your face are you
like preparing for that are you
impromptu or a combination here's the
arc for that and that's actually a great
question because
so when i started in wwe um
the first couple probably the first six
months or so i wrote all my own stuff
because that's just how it was there's a
famous
uh promo i did with the rock my it was
my big debut into wwe and
this big long i interrupted the rock and
it was a big thing in
1999 because he was super hot then too
and there was no rehearsal there was no
lines there was no
script nothing so then as the wwe
progressed they started getting into
they got they got a show on whatever the
network was fox whatever show
whatever network friends was on so when
they got their their major
network show smackdown we're gonna go
head-to-head with friends
we're gonna beat friends that's vince's
attitude right so to do that we need
writers like they have on friends well
it doesn't work that way in wrestling
because friends are
if i'm you know a damaged swimmer
playing ross i'm not david schwimmer i'm
ross
in wrestling it's almost like seinfeld
it's jerry seinfeld
playing a version of jerry seinfeld on
the show seinfeld but it's not really
him
but it is kind of him it's the same with
wrestling right chris jericho is
a character but it's also mostly me
turned up to the 10th degree
so i can't have somebody write something
go here's what you're gonna say chris
that'd be like somebody writing my
answers for you uh as we're doing this
podcast
you have to have a mind of your own and
and
so it it it became a real
sterile kind of like here's your script
and everyone be standing there with the
scripts like a table read
except for we don't have six days of
shooting for this we've got
you know we're on in 60 minutes and it's
a live thing and there's you know
here's my line here's you and some of us
are not actors i am but some aren't and
so it just turns into something
completely unorganic when i left
wwe came to aew a couple years ago which
is our show now that we do every week on
the tnt network owned by
the family that owns the jacksonville
jaguars
we're doing great ratings we just
resigned with tnt
for 10 gazillion schoolian dollars
whatever one of the reasons why it works
is because
it was the first time in 18 years that
when i had a promo
there was no script it was just me like
what do you want me to say like whatever
you want to say it's like okay well now
you have to go back to where it used to
be and say okay
okay jericho everyone says you're good
on the mic are you as good as you think
you are
are you as good as everybody else thinks
you are because now you got to get out
there and just say it off the table and
boom it was so easy
so our promos now are just off the top
of our head going through what we want
to say yes we have bullet points
but a lot of it happens on the fly it's
very similar to
you know improv being an improv
performer you know if
you've worked at the groundlings or
something like when i work with the
groundlings you follow each other's
leads you listen to what the crowd is
doing you go here
you know what the point that you're
trying to make is but it's never as
regimented as saying
you say this i say this learn your lines
and it makes it so much more organic so
much more fun and everybody gets a
chance to really show their characters
which makes everybody more popular